I'm coming for you. you seek the truth
Novu, if you wish to know all, show your
allegiance and all will be revealed that
sounds great oh wait no I don't barter
with false gods
Bow down to me! And all you desire shall be yours.
Let me in!
Let Me In!
Bow down to me!
Planet after Planet.
earth after Earth I've tracked you know Novu and you think some paltry mind games and little
rock wall is going to stop me you've got
another thing coming I'm coming for you
and you can't stop me
for so many years I've traveled across
worlds across the multiverse to do one
thing kill you and now here
you save my life. submit and begin your
life anew
show me the knowledge is within you
welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new crisis on Infinite
Earths video for that opening scene that
they attached to the end of all the
recent midseason finales of the other
shows if you don't remember they did the
exact same thing last year right before
the Elseworlds crossover with the
Elseworlds flash of earth and 90's scene
that they attached all the end of the
episodes it was a whole bunch of Easter
eggs I'll also cover stuff from the
flash midseason finale and this too so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the crisis on
Infinite Earths videos it starts this
Sunday that's right crisis is here we'll
do a flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best theory about crisis on the
video how is it going to end well what's
happening here is team flash is watching
a wave of antimatter approaching their
solar system turning the skies red just
like it said in the future newspapers
since season 1 then you have the more
important scene of Nashville's thinking
that he's confronting the monitor Marno
vu that we've been seeing most of this
season interact with the characters we
also saw him during last year's
crossover - there's a couple secrets
that they're trying to slip past you in
this scene some of you I've seen in the
comments have picked up on what they're
doing the person speaking to Nash wells
is the same actor who plays the monitor
but the actor is playing both the
monitor and the anti-monitor during the
crossover at the same time in the same
way that Tom Cavanaugh plays multiple
different characters within seasons of
the flash like he's a reverse flash but
he's also Nash wells two completely
different characters that look kind of
the same
so listen really carefully to this clip
of the monitor speaking to Oliver in the
heroes during the crisis trailer and
then listen to him yelling at Nash wells
in this clip the multiverse
every existence multiplied by
possibility and spread out an infinite
measure now there is a malevolent force
at work one driven by a singular goal
the destruction of old there is I don't
part it with false gods
most of you probably noticed the
differences in those two voices it
sounds like they're supposed to be
different characters even though it's
the same actor just like Tom Cavanagh
when he's performing reverse-flash
speaks with a very different voice than
when he's speaking his nashville's there
was a deleted scene from one of the
previous crossovers where he actually
does a scene with himself in its reverse
flash going up against earth to harrison
wells and he just goes back and forth
doubling the scene but he does it with
very distinct performances for each
character so that you can tell who is
who now think about what this actor who
normally plays the monitor is saying
when he yells at Nash wells he's
demanding that he bow down to him and
worship him like a God has this version
of the monitor ever said anything
remotely close to that he's asked Oliver
and the rest of them to help him save
the multiverse he's put big tasks on
them but at no point has he ever
referred to himself as a god or demanded
that anyone bow to him and worshiped the
ground that he walks on the person
speaking to Nash wells in this scene has
a completely different personality so
early theory Nash Wells here only thinks
that he's been tracking the monitor
Marno vu this whole time when in fact
he's actually been tracking the
anti-monitor who looks remarkably
similar to the monitor at least right
now they have similar costumes just some
subtle differences in their facial hair
and costume accents but if you weren't
looking closely or listening on good
speakers you wouldn't be able to tell
the difference between these two
characters and I think that's part of
the point of this scene Nash wells is
becoming pariah from comic-book crisis
on Infinite Earths this is what his
costume looks like in all the trailers
after he becomes pariah really what the
anti-monitor is doing or at least he
implies he's doing is revealing the
grand truth of existence the secret of
life or anti life in whatever case in
the multiverse to him that gift is also
meant to be pariahs curse just like
comic book pariah was cursed for his
pursuit of ancient forbidden knowledge
comic book pariah was actually trying to
peer back to the dawn of the universe to
see the Big Bang and that's what alerted
the anti-monitor to the positive matter
universe so that's why he was cursed he
tipped off the event that began crisis
in the comics the seven symbols on the
door here are the symbols representing
the seven different Paragons that the
good version of the
is trying to collect to save the
multiverse it's unclear which symbol
references which Paragon but it's also
unclear how the anti-monitor is
hijacking this place here but the origin
story of the DCTV version of the
anti-monitor will probably be different
than the comic book anti-monitor just
think of this as Nashville's dialing the
cosmic phone to try and get the monitor
and new phone who dis the anti-monitor
winds up picking up Pariah's comic book
power is that once he is cursed he
becomes immortal and his penance is that he instantly gets teleported to each
universe in the multiverse right before
it gets wiped by the anti-monitor he's
forced to watch everyone die then he
gets portals to the next epicenter and
so on and so forth
across each of the universes when they
get wiped but this scene is meant to
take place right at the beginning of
crisis so talking about the flash
midseason finale there was a lot of
other stuff that happened during that
episode there were a couple big Easter
eggs and references they captured
bloodwork and they put him in the same
device that they put Chester P trunk in
to just sort of negate his powers and
keep him contained but he'll come back
at some point later this season they
didn't completely get rid of him they
just put him in the deep freeze
the title of the episode was called The
Last Temptation of Barry Allen a
reference to the Last Temptation of
Christ cisco referenced the babel
protocols from Batman's Tower of Babel
storyline in the Justice League comics
his protocols and plans for how to take
out other members of the Justice League
if they ever turned evil so Cisco back
during season four built one of those
into the brand new version the flash
suit at the time the version that we see
in this episode is just a giant force
field around STAR Labs to prevent Barry
when he turns evil from misusing the
particle accelerator even though they
end up using that in the episode to
solve their problem they name-dropped
HR wells from season 3 at the end of the
episode when they're remembering all the
good times with Barry and all the crazy
stuff they've done the last six seasons
they got a little overly sentimental but
they referenced flashpoint the
doppelgangers from season two was zoom
and the earth to people time travel
being stuck in the Speed Force and iris
having to go get him it was them
basically saying goodbye to Barry before
crisis happened because they all think
that he's going to die but I know a lot
of you are still asking what's going on
with the velocity X or velocity 10 the
fake god speed army black hole the
ultraviolet villain and then maybe some
other
new villains that'll pop up at the
second half of the season we're still
waiting on reverse-flash to show up
during crisis but he will be part of the
crossover the velocity 10 is probably
connected to what's going on with the
black hole plot that we'll all probably
connect in black hole will be one of the
major villains of the back half of the
season in the comics they're obsessed
with studying the Speed Force and using
it for their own personal gain so that's
what I think that velocity X will have
something to do with that and they'll
have something to do with the fake god
speeds but everyone post your theories
in the comments below remember crisis on Infinite Earths Episode one is on Sunday
night so of course I'll be doing Easter
Egg videos for all the episodes everyone
click here for that brand new crisis on
Infinite Earths trailer and click here
for that brand new Black Widow trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight!